les la récente publication des chiffres
de la construction neuve pour 2022
confirme ce que nous n'avons cessé de
dire depuis plusieurs mois à plusieurs
ici au gouvernement la situation n'est
pas dramatique elle est catastrophique
rarement on a connu des chiffres aussi
dramatiques moins 25% pour les
promoteurs privés moins 30% pour les
constructions individuelles 350
000 unités prévues en 2023 pour mémoire
après le plan de relance de Jean-Louis
Borloo on était à
486040% de moins annoncé pour l'année
qui vient et ça va continuer des
faillites en cascade sont annoncés dans
la promotion pour le logement social la
réforme Funès des aPL de la loi Elan a
assécher les finances des offices d'HLM
et on est pour la troisième année
consécutive en dessous des 100 000
logements sociaux
sans parler des mesures que vous avez
prises sur un certain nombre de sujets
par exemple le 0 artificialisation net
heureusement que le Sénat est en train
de les corriger donc monsieur le
ministre ma question est simple est-ce
que vous avez prévu enfin un plan de
relance pour relancer la construction
neuve dans notre pays comme nous l'avons
fait avec succès sous Nicolas Sarkozy
Jacques Chirac est-ce que vous avez
prévu des mesures fiscales de relance
exceptionnelle comme nous avons réussi à
le faire sous le gouvernement de
François Fillon